[Music]
[Music]
I'm the one
[Music]
pickleball
everybody's talking about it so anyways
today's guest special guest
if you ever watched Entourage my dad and
I that say we watched Laker games
together we watched Entourage together
and it was mandatory and the man who
created entourage is on the podcast
today Doug Ellen Doug thanks for being
on thanks for having me yes so we were
we were talking about a bunch of
different stuff there's breaking news
Tyler's about to tell us something
happened on Nancy Pelosi's husband we're
going to talk about Elon Musk taking
over Twitter we're going to talk about
conditions of Hollywood LA California
your thoughts on Kanye a lot of stuff is
going on back to back to back lots
happening yes and last night you said
you had a uh a long day at a profession
Semi-Pro pickleball tournament yeah I
mean this is real deal I mean uh Danny
werfel has this charity uh Desire Street
Ministries and he put together this
event which is incredible Kevin Anderson
who's top five ATP tennis tour in the
last five years of course everyone knows
pickleball
did he play late 90s or 2000s I would
say midnight yeah
[Music]
same era yeah Danny you know it's
probably top five NCAA quarterbacks of
all time and uh so it was a it was a
Pro-Am but it was serious come Rick
Barry Hall of Fame uh NBA player you
know I think he's got a higher shooting
percentage from the foulan and Steph
Curry shoot like this yes yes he did the
underhand shoot I mean cheating
produced great Shooters he produced one
of them won a dunk contest
you know dunking it I think from uh uh
free throw online yeah yeah it's a big
deal
he's also the only guy to ever win a NBA
dunk contest in the warm-ups he didn't
take it wasn't in a jersey yeah that's
right white boy Duncan from the free
throw line warm-ups and by the way I
know everyone's gonna laugh at
pickleball but trust me the world is
changing I've been promoting this for
five years and and now it's it's really
coming to pass and real athletes are
getting involved professional tennis
players so it's pretty cool so Pat
should buy a team 100 I mean what are
they going for what's up it's a million
bucks right now but they're not like
offering up a you know 20 of them and uh
hopefully we'll I'm trying to get
involved so hopefully for a professional
League you can buy one for a million
bucks yeah I mean the professional
League started like a month ago this
thing is all exploded and LeBron's got
one Tom Brady's got one yeah I'm trying
to get one we'll see come on you can do
it you could do it we'll see we'll see
maybe it depends how it goes today off
camera yes it's a million bucks I mean
by the way rather than going to lunch
you guys we have to preface what
happened oh Jesus because you're saying
pickleball last night we had Antonio
Brown here sitting in your chair right
there oh and we were there for three
hours and it was
I want to say most
I don't even know how to describe
heated yeah like at any point something
could have happened it was intense
constant until the last 45 minutes for
sure and we talked everything we talked
enjoyable
you have to see it it was it was a the
climax was good the ending was great
because we we got to uh we just got to
talking and it was eventually fine but
at first it was extremely what was what
was the Tipping Point of crazy it's just
taking the headset we'll stop this thing
right now I got up got some water we
started just you know so it's a real
podcast yeah it was dope yeah but it had
to get there because it was it was but I
will tell you this the audience when
they see the podcast they're not they're
gonna be glued to the screen scene
what's going on 100 I think you're gonna
be no no you're gonna be so confused
yeah 45 minutes you know you guys got
higher budgets than we got because we
got a call right when he started acting
crazy and said do you want Antonio Brown
on your podcast yeah yeah and they said
all right we need a bag and I was like a
bag and they're like yeah cash and I
said how much cash you want they wanted
20 grand for them to come on the Pod to
be on the podcast yeah you know he might
have done less for you you have a bigger
audience yeah was it security by the way
that is becoming a business model the
the part about the the nowadays people
are calling saying hey will you be on my
podcast for 10 grand will you be on my
podcast for 20 grand will you be on
people are now paying to get podcasts
and the bigger guess you got to pay more
for to have you on your podcast that's
uh it's becoming a business model oh
yeah he's an interesting guy I'll say
this about uh Antonio Brown got real
awkward eh I mean uh you've done I even
said I go because at one point he's like
you don't know where I'm from you know
we were like Antonio listen with all the
respect we sat down with Killers Mafia
guys okay the biggest politicians in the
world UFC fighters that kill for a
living like Marines CIA with all due
respect like just kind of kind of
g-check you first like I get it you're a
football player but like
you know what it's it seems like you
know they're talking about all the head
injuries in the NFL and it seems right
now we're seeing a lot of them go crazy
make fun of them because it's sad that's
where yeah the fire it's in one minute
yeah just because of that
30 minutes of arguing over that comment
right there the word the word CTE came
up he brought it up before us very soon
and then it just
you know I'm sure I'm sure it's a
sensitive issue for them because they
don't even realize what's happening
exactly you know and uh you know with
mental illness awareness right now you
know obviously you can't excuse his
behavior still but it's it's sad what do
you think what's going on with uh
because you know he's still the
president of down the academy yeah
Antonio Brown is the president of down
the yeah I want to send my kids I
definitely want to get him so what do
you think what's going on with Kanye
what do you I mean he said a lot of
different things but why why was this
the Tipping Point what do you think
about what's going on with them well you
know what I I mean again
getting into mental illness I don't
excuse behavior for mental illness and I
also I'm a Jew
um but as a Jew I don't want to make
this only about Jews because I think
this country is becoming so polarized
with everything and anytime someone
speaks like this everybody should speak
up whether it's about Muslims whether
it's about police officers it's all the
same stuff and and so what do I think is
going on with Kanye I think he's having
some type of bipolar episode but who
gives a [ __ ] it's like you know he's he
and again you know somehow this became a
free speech issue speak all you want and
everybody else should speak also and I
should have the right to not buy your
[ __ ] crappy sneakers and do whatever
else but um you know it's it's sad to
see because what what happens is and I
see it I have a lot of friends who are
police officers in L.A and this real
world consequences to this stuff kids
get threatened at schools and some guy
walking down the street gets punched in
the face and and um Nazis are on the 405
so again end though just separating it
from because I don't want to just make
it all about his comments about Jews
it's just you know like we're in this
we're in this place right now in the
state where everybody wants to make the
groups even worse and I swear to you
it's so nuts that 10 years ago I thought
my kids were gonna be in a colorblind
world I really was stupid enough to
believe in the last three years we have
gone backwards in ways that is is quite
frightening you think so yeah oh yeah
tell me what how do we get there I think
the media I think the media you watch
both sides of it I mean CNN will put
every single day how racist the country
is how awful cops are and you know of
course there are bad cops there's bad
everything there's bad football players
like Antonio Brown you know I'm in this
just bad people everywhere so and then
Fox on the other side you know they put
Kanye on they cut out all his
anti-semitic comments and then you know
I posted on Instagram I really didn't
think there was going to be any other
side to this conversation I just thought
yeah I just said everybody unite we
shouldn't speak badly about any groups
not indians not police not you know
whatever and all of a sudden I'm getting
this you're a censorship guy you're this
and I'm far from a censorship guy I mean
I'm I'm interested to see what happens
with Elon and Twitter
um but I believe in free speech and um
It's just sad to see a guy with his
platform uh speak like this and endanger
so many people you know and for what
what does he get out of it I don't I
don't know do you think the
repercussions he got you know Adidas
Cuts ties okay that's that costs him a
couple billion dollars uh Balenciaga
Cuts ties Vogue and a winter Cuts ties
drop by CAA drop eyes lawyers all these
Spotify up you know their downloads are
you know decreasing and Spotify hasn't
made a decision to drop them yet they're
thinking about keeping him just like
they kept Rogan when Rogan was everybody
wanted him to be canceled restricted
from Instagram and Twitter
stadium shows canceled documentaries
shelved 120 million dollars of cash left
yesterday he said he's lost everything
and his net worth dropped 2 billion in a
day yeah what was the Tipping Point
because he set stuff for oh he wore the
White lives matter that drove a lot of
people insane when he wrote that a
couple weeks ago yeah but what's a
Tipping Point well you know everybody's
going to say it's it's it's the Jews and
we control everything and that's what
happened so
um you know I don't know what the
Tipping Point is and I you know I don't
believe he's I don't believe he's got
any financial problems and anytime soon
but
um you're not thinking about like doing
a GoFundMe
I'm just thinking if you want to come up
with the idea I paid him you know Kanye
was on Entourage I paid like uh 1100
bucks so he probably still has that in
his that's all you had to pay him yeah
yeah I mean honestly they called us to
be honest so um that was how it worked
with all our cameos they came on so but
it was but everybody wanted to be on
yeah like that was the show to be on
yeah people probably would have done it
for free to be on this yeah well yeah
the only reason we paid whenever we paid
yeah yeah but I mean first year it was
impossible to get anybody you know Mark
Wahlberg I almost I didn't know if Mark
was going to show up for his cameo in
the first episode I remember and he was
the executive producer yeah
are you coming are you this you got 1100
bucks for me I'm sure we were when we
started and then by season two people
started calling us but with Kanye look
it's a long road and we'll see how long
this lasts or whatever and again I'm not
trying to keep the guy down he's an
incredible Talent
um you know and I don't want to just see
him come out and go oh I'm sorry I'd
like to get my money back and um I just
you know you want to see someone be
educated and understand how dangerous it
is to lump people into groups and any
groups you know I you know he's got
problems with you know some Jewish music
Executives I'm sure there's a million
people who do but when he talks about
controlling the media Rupert Murdoch is
the biggest guy in the media by a
million [ __ ] miles he's not Jewish
and you don't normally say you know you
don't you don't here oh you had a bad
interaction with this Catholic guy you
know because these [ __ ] Catholics are
killing us I mean I don't know what
they're doing well so exactly it's sadly
and why it's so scary for for Jewish
people is we're such a small group and
somehow it always comes back and I've
been saying it for years you'll see
eventually the right and the left
somehow comes together and goes against
us and um and again I still I really
don't want to make it just about his
Jewish comments I think people speaking
hate about any groups you know speak out
against it I'm not saying he should be
off Twitter I'm not saying he should be
off Instagram or anything else but I'm
not gonna go see his concerts you know
and I have I have before I think I think
it all started going downhill when when
Trump was in he started wearing the Maga
hat and that's where all the publicity
and everything came in but what makes it
like weird is that you know you don't
see oh I've never seen somebody so
influential somebody's a billionaire
person with such a platform that has a
mental illness that people like TMZ
everybody they just want to see him in
here yeah you know what I'm saying
they're just like put them in front more
and more and more more if you're going
TMZ right now it's just him yeah well
everybody will put him on would you put
them on who him yeah absolutely yeah so
I mean you know I I put them on I'd put
him on our podcast if he wanted to come
on I won't give him a bag but yeah the
biggest the biggest thing is is you know
guys have made comments before
anti-semitic comments before so for me
when you hear comments being made you
know and and you sit there and you watch
it like okay Jimmy Kimmel Still's got a
show and back in the days you know hey
Howard Stern is a rock star and you want
to see what Howard Stern did one time as
a skit years ago he's still got a 600
million whatever's on massive contract
so there's the the hypocrisy is what's
the most annoying thing I do think it's
times and I'm never gonna say blackface
is okay or something but I can tell you
when I was a kid and I never put on
blackface there's no pictures of me I
wanted to be Eddie Murphy so badly when
I was a child that I I would dress up as
Buckwheat for Halloween now I did not do
blackface but I can tell you I when I
was a 12 year old kid I had no idea that
this would offend people and what and
Howard Stern again I'm not going to
defend Howard Stern but you know Robin
has been his partner for 30 40 years and
I think Howard Stern is a liberal I so
part of it is you know whether you're
doing art whether it's good art bad art
that's a whole different issue than when
you as a person go I have a problem with
this group of people I have a problem
with Indians the last three years
everybody's telling me they got a
problem with white people I mean they're
not being canceled yeah you got people
talking about they got problems with
whiteness and you know all these and I'm
not even white I'm Iran and I'm in the
middle I'm not black I'm not white I'm
probably the one that gets targeted more
being a guy born and raised in Iran but
you hear these comments being made about
whites ah it's totally fine but you hear
the comments being made about the other
side oh my God so I understand what
you're saying I'm not saying to I
actually didn't make the comment about
Kimmel about him getting canceled I
don't think he needs to get canceled I
don't think Howard needs to get canceled
I don't think I'm glad Rogan didn't get
canceled they almost try to get that guy
yeah canceled and Spotify stood behind
him and then eventually they didn't so
with Kanye here he's pushing the
envelope
extremely like to to say a comment what
was the comment to use uh uh he says I'm
gonna go
yeah I mean yeah that's not I can't do
that kind of show you can't but but by
the way the way you handle that yeah is
the way musk handled it and he called
him he says hey what are you doing yeah
and they had a conversation I just had a
conversation with Kanye he seemed
sincere
and you know he's gonna work on this
area and boom he kept him on he didn't
get worse I mean it got worse he goes on
everything and and says worse stuff and
again I'm not suggesting who should
cancel and the question is which I was
talking to some friends last night about
it I mean Adidas the company has fallen
apart as is and this was an enormous
Financial loss for them so I'm sure for
getting their Nazi past which they have
which is the founder to me is somewhat
irrelevant you know because it's it's I
don't believe in the sins of your father
should be on this but I'm sure there
were terrifying discussions inside this
company and people who are going to lose
their jobs and people have to feed their
families and all that stuff so it's hard
for me to just go you know put myself in
a position oh you know what I can make
100 million dollars today with Kanye or
I can just go you know what I'm gonna
make a stand but
I am glad that they did and I don't
think that's cancel culture I think
that's going I don't want you out in
front of my company spewing this
nonsense and this garbage and again I
don't and I understand as an Iranian
what you're saying but the sad thing is
with the with all the comments when they
come after white people and Howard Stern
who I is one of my favorites I mean
Howard he used to have uh Daniel Carver
on the racist and the Jews were always
the lowest group we were below everybody
so the weird thing is we kind of look
like we're white but then we're not
really so we get into this group where
everybody comes after us and and you
know but again I'm just trying to say as
as corny as it sounds it's like enough
grouping any group together there's do
you have a problem with a Jewish guy or
an Iranian guy that's your problem with
him 100 that's it I'll make a couple
points uh Point number one by the way
just so you guys know we've made history
yeah it's the first time in the history
of the podcast we got two series and two
Jews yeah exactly yeah that's actually
what I was going to bring up oh my God
honestly enough who's another Jewish I'm
Jewish who's the other Jew come on who's
the other dude I don't like to you know
I don't like The Stereotype but some
face like thank you brother the the
couple quick points he's did you see the
interview he did with Lex Friedman I saw
some of it so I think Lex is an absolute
stud very just smart thinker just
Brainiac very logical actor and I've
never seen him get emotionally triggered
and he and Kanye did that yeah so when
you can do that to the kind of a
rational logical guy it's Testament to
that but he made a very good point he's
like and this is where they went back
and forth back and forth he's like
listen stop with the group stuff
individuals screwed you over use their
names that's how you get even right Bill
[ __ ] me Rick Rubin [ __ ] whoever it is
yeah you can name them and that's how
you get even and that's how you even the
score now it's also so ridiculous you've
got me I mean I mean these
African-American singers in the 60s
really did get screwed and [ __ ] how
did Kanye get fight he's richer than he
was rich well hire a good Jewish lawyer
to read your [ __ ] contract Point
number two I I think that you talked
about like Adidas specifically or
Balenciaga or Vogue whatever I think
there's a major difference between a
full-on brand a fashion brand distancing
themselves from you versus a Spotify I'm
totally okay if Adidas wants to do their
thing but let's do your thing you don't
want him representing your brand but
Spotify that's his music I'm totally
against that like if he's if he's
rapping about killing Jews all right
maybe but he's not that's not what it is
so I'm fully against that yeah thirdly
and this is we're talking about Jews and
Assyrians you've dealt with this before
where you went into a room to get a job
to be a part of a company and they're
like yeah we don't we don't do business
with the Armenians or Assyrians it just
and you're like what did I do you're
like well we've had a bad experience
it's like Judge Me by the content of my
character not by Martin Luther King and
I think that's ultimately what we're
talking about here absolutely you've
dealt with this PVD yeah I mean look
here's here's the one thing when I was
watching ABS today there's there's a
trend there's a there's a difference
between being a troll
because it works the business model
troll is very effective it's a very very
effective business model to accelerate
uh getting eyeballs look at what Andrew
Tate did he got under people's skins and
boom the most viral man on the internet
no one's getting more eyeballs and the
guy does an interview Boom everybody
wants to know what this guy's got to say
but there there's a thin line like Conor
McGregor was a very good smack talker
until he lost the fight to Dustin Podium
says hey tell your wife to stay out of
my DMs and then boom he crossed the line
there when you're talking about trolling
there's a line for trolling you don't
cross when him and Mayweather were
growing at it great it sold tickets we
were all curious uh you know the fight
when what nine or ten rounds but he was
a professional troller so was Mayweather
so was Trump so are a lot of these guys
Jake Paul major troller it's a very very
effective business model these days it
is it's generally always been though but
but the way it was done before was in a
different way Muhammad Ali and everybody
they were just Robert Maxwell know
jerlane's father was a troll going after
Murdoch and Murdoch was trolling him
this trolling concept with Onassis
trolling John F Kennedy this is not a
new new thing right but the difference
is if I may social media has Amplified
that right because now you can do your
own distribution you don't have to rely
on no question about it you know
and then there is and then there is
like you know it's like you know
sometimes like uh you you're trying to
get attention you're trying to look
let's just say sometimes a podcast is
not doing good or show is not doing good
yeah and they're like man I gotta I
gotta show some boobs I gotta show
something this I gotta show some bot I
haven't been getting a lot of likes on
my Instagram I gotta say some crazy [ __ ]
to you and then he's like no man now now
your business model is too reliant on
how everybody reacts to you and you lose
authenticity that's when you get up
again I don't know what anybody else
does because I've never had that in my
brain I've always tried to be as
authentic as I can and I try to to just
speak in a way that that hopefully
speaks to all groups because and and
we're going to keep repeating the same
thing but you know you want to troll
somebody you're pissed at somebody's
specific troll them specifically but
once you start lumping in groups it's
it's it's dangerous yeah but like I said
it's a long road part of me thinks Kanye
is this is all uh exactly what you're
talking about he's trolling all of us
and while he lost some money at the
moment he'll be back and he'll have an
album in a year and it'll be this and
and it'll be and it'll be huge you know
provided it's good well before the Jews
which is the the you know throughout
history they've been a major scapegoat
right now obviously over the last couple
years it's been Asians yeah oh you're
Chinese clearly you've given everybody
covet like no yeah I'm from Vietnam I'm
from Hong Kong like stop looping
grouping me into this it's a very
slippery slope and it ends up getting a
work where it gets very up nobody did
that nobody did nobody did what nobody
said you're Chinese you're the one that
gave me the vibe are you kidding me
Asian hate was a real thing no nobody
did that that was that was that was what
no nobody did that was a campaign to pin
again the same thing he's been taught my
last three years is to pin Bill acts
against whites CNN against Fox this is
the stuff that they make up that you
believe and you're like oh my God this
nobody did that nope I I never went to a
person saying yeah Kobe is because of
your fault you didn't because you're not
an idiot no no but but people did do it
stop people I'm not gonna like this is a
real thing this is not a real thing this
is this is what this is the Asian people
have been beat up up because of this
there are actual stories yeah and real
life actual case examples yeah of these
exact scenarios but why though but why
though because some people know elements
no Society don't go [ __ ] idiots and
they'll take go to this give them an
inch they'll take them out go to the
seed go to the seed the root of the
issue is when a CNN or MSNBC or the
media says constantly this is what's
happening and then there is reaction to
it to get the attention that's why we
can't sit here and naively think people
are going around because somebody from
the top says Kobe came from these guys
and they're blame the same thing can be
said when they said covet is because of
the Trump's fault no covert is this
person's fault cover is that Prince's
fault so we can play that card all we
want the same story can be said on the
other side the moral of the story is the
best thing that Doug just said is the
final one I said he says I feel like
we're going backwards and I asked why he
says media and you turn on the media
broadcasting your body hates each other
we don't we don't we don't hate each
other I mean we can sit down and have a
civil conversation and figure things out
you know we can sit down not everything
that happens is because people are
judging the other person one scenario
doesn't mean as a million scenarios
where people are being convinced one
instance of a issue happening is
happening a million times everywhere
it's not it's happening here and there
so the more you promote it it gets to
nine people 100 people 700 people 20 000
people that's how this kind of [ __ ] gets
started I don't disagree with that I'll
say one caveat it takes a seed to plant
a tree a million times yeah hear me out
here oftentimes a small story a real
story an actual case example of an Asian
guy getting beat up or a black guy like
a George Floyd getting killed what like
that actually happened the media will
water it and water it and give it
fertilizer and grow that [ __ ] and
amplify it but it did start with an
actual example do you remember the the
thing that was going viral in the
streets of New York where kids were
going around knocking people out and I
just called something knockout game
old people yeah whose fault was that
yeah so say that incident happened 20
times now all of a sudden ever everybody
is putting it out there now other kids
want to go do it now their kids are
noticing people are becoming celebrities
they record me while I'm doing this
you're feeding the machine you're
feeding the Beast well the news is I
mean it isn't even the news anymore it's
just fear-mongering and you know and
it's it's honestly it's not even new
though I remember when I moved to LA and
I'm from New York you know I grew up
with murderers and stuff and when I got
to La everyone's like they carjack you
in La be real careful and I remember in
La I would drive around Beverly Hills in
1990 and like pull up like eight feet
from a red light so I could [ __ ]
Escape if anyone attacked me and it is
you watch the news or whatever they want
to call the news and every five seconds
they are showing you something that you
should be scared of and they're not
really giving you any way out of it
they're not giving you like news should
be okay there's a hurricane coming you
might want to get out you know you're
not um you know everybody's getting
killed every five well I don't remember
you Doug you're a little bit older than
me but I don't know if you remember but
news used to be a non-monetizable a
monetizable asset it was the news they
weren't looking to make money off of it
it was a it was almost like a free thing
for society and when they started to
monetize news oh we can make money off
this oh the bigger personalities and the
more sensationalized that we can do
things this is a cash cow this is a
money maker let's get some people that
get eyeballs and now today with social
media and amplification changed but and
I know everybody loves like Cronkite and
stuff but the reality is it's it's still
you know even when you're reporting news
even if it was 30 years ago it's skewed
by somebody's vision of what they think
of who who's being oppressed or who's
this what they want to show whether it
was Vietnam or whatever it was so
um it's it's a scary thing but at the
same time we need it because you need
access and that's why free speech is so
important but right now it's also the
really hard thing I mean you can just
read the New York Times and then you can
go read somewhere else something the
exact same story and you go holy [ __ ]
yeah that was like I don't know what to
think anymore except I do know that the
times has got a liberal slant to it no
matter what they want to claim so it
it's a very confusing time and it's a
scary time for for young people
especially and and you know I think I
think what we're seeing with like the
mental illness crisis is because people
are so [ __ ] up and they are so kind of
lost as to which way to turn and and
hopelessness a little bit I think is
entering the equation where you just go
what the [ __ ] is the point we can't you
know have a normal minute ever so yeah
and don't forget speaking of like Legacy
Media back in the day was three major
Outlets yeah ABC NBC CBS and then Fox
showed up in the 90s it's like who are
these new guys on the Block yeah right
and that and now there's 10 billion
different channels go get whatever you
want there's something for you yeah I
didn't change the game tet Turner is a
legendary guy who started a business
model which was 24 7 news and everybody
thought that was crazy he almost wristed
up he wrist it all and then next thing
you know he ends up buying the Falcons
buying the Braves I don't know who he
bought he freaking pretty much bought
half the world and then he ran for
office he almost became a president so
Ted Turner created that model of
constant news which seemed really good
yeah and it was and it was really good
and now you look at it but it's weird
even with CNN now unless I'm crazy
because I stopped watching it during the
pandemic I mean Cuomo and Don Lemon were
getting me to the point of like you know
everybody hates if one side hates Tucker
Carlson one side hates I hate both of
them I just think they are good you know
I think they're a lot better to live
that way yeah I mean I just think they
are trying everything they can to make
everyone hate each other and they're
laughing all the way to the bank because
they get paid to do this but CNN I feel
like unless I'm crazy I've clicked on a
little bit I feel like they've moved a
little right all of a sudden like
suddenly they've not they're trying to
get back
firing a bunch of people and getting rid
of a bunch of people but the CNN I'm
talking about if you ever read the book
by Ted Turner okay I don't know if
you've read it or I have not highly
recommended it you wrote this a while
back I will because I love tattoo oh my
god dude you're gonna you won't be able
to put it down it's that if you download
the audiobook and on your flight back
you finish it you'll be able to finish
it at 1.5 speed what's the name of the
book it's called Ted I think they call
me Ted I think that's what 1.5 speed I
do 2.0 I do 2.0 this guy would go 4.0 if
he could I'm gonna you can on Spotify
3.5 and it's fantastic but but going
back go back to this going back to this
when you hear How It Ends
what what his level of disappointment
with CNN how the book ends and this is
not a new book can you pull up the book
just just type in what the uh uh Ted
Turner book it's not a it's not a new
book it's an older book not Teddy that's
a porn
it autocorrects it's too early say they
call me Teddy call me
oh my God time
call me that book right there yeah by
the way it's 13 years old which is
perfect because nothing was happened it
wasn't like 13 years old so that book is
due for a bar mitzvah oh that sounds
like 09 is what it is so but CNN was a
guy that changed the game and everything
else came after that I will say
something about CNN
um no doubt nationally it has a tainted
image in my opinion and from what I talk
to especially people in actually CNN
International has a different cachet
globally like CNN International which
obviously we don't watch one of the
states does still have a high level of
credibility and that's essentially you
know the international arm of what Tim
was so you watch a lot of CNN
Internationals they actually do very
very I'm thinking about what they're
thinking over a little bit around the
world
they just think we're a third world
country think about it it's not as you
know us-based left-right you know
conservative liberal Trump yes no
Dynamics right it's just international
news
by the way so for a guy that built
entourage on you know which by the way
some may call it the greatest show of
all time to me it's a top five of mine I
think it's just insane if you when you
ask some people that are newer guy
younger guys they're in their 20s like
have you seen a what's on to rush I'm
like dude you missed out I slapped them
right in the face
it's not like you don't know what life
is more by watching but but you do this
and it becomes a phenomenon it becomes a
uh everyone's talking about it at work
the next day everyone's talking about it
at the peak of insanity tell us a crazy
insane story when Entourage was peaking
how the the in the community how
Hollywood was looking at it tell us tell
us some crazy stories about the whole
Entourage movement I mean I'm trying to
think what crazy stories I have but you
know I I always even though I wrote that
show I was always kind of like a head
down guy and and I'm not kind of living
in anything like that Entourage Life In
fact when when Mark brought it to me
because Mark said I want to do a show
about me and my friends like and I'm
like a bunch of hanger ons who hang out
with a movie star I'm like it's just not
my speed and and and you know he he said
think about it and I went home and
thought about how to make these guys
like a family and and that's you know
any any successful show that's
essentially what they are but I mean
it's you know it's not an insane story
but when my brother my my Harvard Law
brother who worked at Staten Arps and is
Mr Conservative and like I don't think I
ever thought like I was even mildly
amusing to him when like when the hug it
out thing happens which honestly it was
I mean I've written far better lines
than that and had no expectation of this
being a thing but when my brother told
me like his whole office in scat in Arps
New York all these Harvard guys that you
know like I I could never even visit
Harvard I was too stupid to do that so
when I hear that they were talking about
it and then when the athletes would call
LeBron James and Tom Brady like we want
to be on the show that's crazy um it was
it was really wild Phil Mickelson I mean
um you know I wrote this line or maybe
Brian Birds wrote this live whatever but
he's melting down like all right say
he's melting down like like Mickelson at
Wingfoot which was like his famous U.S
open meltdown and then I see him and I'm
like hey Doug Ellen and he looks at me
he goes you know I'm sitting in bed with
my wife minding my own business watching
my favorite show
and this comes on you know and uh so I
said well come on the show and he still
came on so it's it for him it was a very
it was a very cool wild ride in the town
really embraced the show which you know
speaking of cancer culture when it
started to turn that all of a sudden the
show was racist homophobic in this I'm
like okay well it was Obama's favorite
show you know the New York Times but it
is the best show you know and and it's
weird to see how I don't think the world
has shifted as much as as you just said
it really hasn't shifted but there's
just a lot of loud voices that are
getting a lot of air and a lot of
attention and a lot of power could you
do Entourage today and get away with it
well you know would you be having to
explain yourself every day for an
episode look I I have a new show that
I'm doing now that I believe will will
be speak to society in 2022 the way that
did in 2003. the reality is the real Ari
could never speak the way he did in an
office so I would never write that so
when people write things which it's all
also funny with comedy or you know some
people don't find it funny but with
comedy you get this thing like you can't
say that you can but The Sopranos like
Tony Soprano can you know Murder his his
son's you know best friend's father or
beat him up or threaten him whatever and
that's that's okay because it's somehow
more artistic but
um I wouldn't write things that that
don't exist just like you wouldn't write
a show in 2022 where people you know
cars don't exist I mean things evolve
things change society's changing what I
think hopefully what I did well and why
it captured the culture is is I
understood what Hollywood was like in
2003 and by the way it was mild compared
to reality you know and but it still did
speak of some reality and some real
world issues Adrian Greiner I mean out
of all the guys there Kevin's been
acting since he was six years old he's
been in Hollywood for a long time right
you know you can and I'm saying Connell
you can go through everybody Kevin
Dylan's been asking yeah
Jeremy piven's been acting for 40
freaking years at this point incredible
actor but but what did age where did you
guys find him so Adrian was uh pull up
the picture for some people that don't
know he's from Entourage go for it
Adrian is for the people that don't know
who he is I I want to spit in your face
entourage is wake up so but but Adrian
Adrian Steve Levinson who was a better
picture Tyler that's him there you go
that's a good picture he gets the worst
picture of the guy go ahead and Chase in
the house Vince so Steve Levinson who I
went to Tulane with and as it was a good
friend and was Mark's manager
um he represented Adrian and Adrian when
we were casting his I I cannot tell you
how hard it is to cast a movie star who
is not a movie star this is literally
one of the hardest things on the planet
and Adrian who is a great actor who
actually Woody Allen cast as a movie
star I think you know opposite Leo and
um I forgot what that movie was called
one of his is less least successful
movies but Adrian would be in this
office every day while we were pulling
our hair out trying to pull it out and
then Steve one day was like you know I
got the guy I'm like who's the guy and
and he's like him and agent had this
beard like we did this episode where he
goes to Mexico and yeah he had this
beard he would always wear a hoodie and
you know and then I'm I'm not a
homophobic guy at all but I don't like
stare at handsome men and go whatever
I'm like the guy in the corner with like
the hoodie and the beard you know and
he's like yeah that's the guy that guy
cleans up nicely yeah but even when he
didn't clean up we just put him on tape
and uh one of our
um one of our assistants did a genius
thing back in 2003 he took Connolly's
audition and he took Adrian's audition
and put him together and Connolly's
Kylie's a handsome guy you know but uh
when we put him together Adrian just he
instantaneously felt like a movie star
you know and um you know some people
like to say he wasn't great anyway let
me tell you something there's very few
people on the planet who could have
pulled off that role and really had this
presence in the show that that just made
you feel like I want to be around this
guy I want to be friends with this guy
and I want to be in his orbit but um so
we we were lucky because we saw every
single person in town and it was tricky
and when I started I wanted I wanted a
Wahlberg which is even harder because
you know as you look around in the
movies there's very few guys like Mark
you know so speaking of Ari Gold was
Jeremy Piven born to play that role like
did you even look elsewhere so I my
agent at CA was a guy named Jeff Jacobs
who I went to Camp with 30 years ago he
was my agent
Jeremy who I'd never met in my life
I loved and from Larry Sanders
specifically so in the first outline
that Harry Shandling is that back in the
day this is the Larry [ __ ] show probably
this is legitimately top five sitcoms
ever made I mean it's genius and uh you
know Bob Odenkirk was the inspiration
for the agent Better Call Saul he was
the agent on Larry Sanderson when I was
thinking of an agent he was kind of my
inspiration but then I saw Jeremy and he
kind of looked like a little bit like my
agent and I so in my first thing I said
Jeremy Piven playing Jeff Jacobs you
know and then what happened was we went
into the pitch meeting at HBO I had
never heard of our Emmanuel I had never
met him nothing but he represented Mark
and Steve Levinson so I was with Jeff
Jacobs and you know they were with Ari
and we walked into the room and I've
told this before but you know I'm
sitting there with 35 pages of like
stories and material for this show and
we walk in and Ari Emmanuel before
anyone says a word goes it's a show
about Mark and his friends this guy is
gonna write it if it sucks we're gonna
fire him and someone else is gonna
rewrite it wow okay says it to your face
oh yeah yeah in the meeting and then uh
so that was pretty much the end of the
meeting I didn't even really have to
speak and uh the first thing I said to
to Steve Levinson after we walked out I
go he's Piven plays him this is the guy
and we then got in the car and Ari calls
I I honestly did not say a word I had a
15-minute pitch ready to say I don't
think I said a word all right goes done
they bought it I said do they want to
like read any of my writing samples and
he goes I just said they bought it would
you like them to unbuy it so so
instantaneously I knew I had a character
that would pop and then I I meet Jeremy
he's gotten into shape and he actually
kind of now looks like Ari it was so
bizarre
um can you pull up a picture of uh
but uh you know um so then we had I had
to convince Jeremy to do the show by the
way so what do you mean convince him he
didn't well he didn't know who I was he
didn't know who any of the other actors
were and we weren't paying a lot it was
a very low budget thing when we started
so uh we met and we convinced him to do
it and it was great and um you know
there was no other options he'll click
on that picture right in the middle
between uh right in the middle between
no no in the middle right there that's
the picture
yeah because that's who he's playing
yeah it's it's wild he's uh he's he's a
great actor though he started doing
stand-up right before the pandemic I
started seeing him at the Laugh Factory
I moved here from L.A he's saying Piven
being pivot and then he all I got off
stage and he was like dude like holy
[ __ ] and like we kind of you know we're
both handsome whatever so so but he was
he was just awesome and like uh he was
like Hey I'm gonna go perform in Utah
one of the uh comedy clubs he's like I
was like I'm gonna go see my sister
she's in the Air Force like dude coming
open for me and feature he's in the back
smoking cigars he's he's he's he's not
cool he saw you do a podcast with how
you live in J Piven his podcast I'm
gonna Circle back to kind of what we
brought up initially and I no doubt I
mean is he the only one who actually won
a an Emmy or something from he's uh as
far as actors he's the only one yeah and
Dylan were both not okay but I mean
obviously he crushed three in a row yeah
which is ridiculous
um
but you brought up a point earlier like
whoa what what are would he be canceled
these days who knows but Sopranos it's
crazy speaking of First Amendment
Sopranos and you can even go down the
depth chart of like whatever you know
murders or Grand Theft Auto you could
full-on murder someone gun to the Head
yeah just blood plus that's fine yeah
but God forbid you call someone a nasty
name oh you'll get it you could do that
on The Sopranos too yeah you can call
them whatever you want but by the way
the crazy thing is with this uh uh show
uh which I'm curious to know about the
business model I'll get into that just I
want to learn a little bit more about
the businessman it's in La okay it's
about like the it's being shot like
mostly the life Entourage yeah so but
then I want to say a month ago you said
I'm done with LA it's a thin line
between becoming more and more common as
City Soft on crimes mixed with inflation
creating on air that's becoming
insufferable for many residents
I was in LA with Kevin uh two months ago
and we went he took me out to a nice
restaurant we're having a conversation
I'm looking outside what was the hotel
uh we were talking about right across
the hotel uh uh
SLS there's a tree house homeless guy
build a treehouse director in Beverly
Hills wow how bad are things in LA right
now from your point of view you know
what it's again that's like where the
media is go read like The New York Times
and they'll tell you this is racist to
talk about but I have had more friends
have interactions with violent crime in
the last year and a half than in the
previous 30 years combined wow so my
ex-wife and my brother's ex-wife are on
the news running for their lives in
Beverly Hills from a shooting at El
pisteo on on Canon I had a friend of
mine with his eight-month pregnant wife
with a guy put a gun to her stomach at
the force right behind the Four Seasons
Hotel
um my ex-wife also grew up with someone
whose mother was killed in Beverly Hills
this year in a if you remember that guy
just walked into her house in Beverly
Hills an 80 year old plus woman and shot
her
um so things are bad you know now I'm
not smart enough to want to get into all
of the stuff whether it's bail reform
whether it's the pandemic where whatever
it was all I know is three years ago it
was a very different place and people
are fleeing at crazy rates and wealthy
people and no matter what anyone wants
to say about that it's going to cause
major problems because we already have
the highest taxes in the country and if
you take away all the high taxpayers
which look I don't make a dollar right
now so Conley pays nothing on this
podcast
so I mean it's it's not you know that's
not my high concern at this particular
second my own taxes but it's just
getting really bad and you know people
don't feel safe you don't want to drive
a nice car you don't want to wear your
watch out and we go is this going to
become Venezuela is this like what the
plan is for this place and you know
again I don't want to speak as if I'm
smart enough to understand these
politicians because I watch them they
they try to find their issues that they
can win on and then they go whether they
believe in anything they're saying I no
longer have any faith in that whatsoever
is it at a point where obviously musk
left Rogan level a lot of people have
left that you you read about the Austin
people come in here people going to
Tennessee people are going to Nevada
some of the guys are going to Nevada
which is the Mark Wahlberg went to some
story came out about him leaving in
Nevada I think the story came out last
week who's the girl from Pretty Woman
Julia Roberts just left as well yeah and
she's going to a completely different
place but is it at a point where you're
thinking about leaving or no that's
where you're going to be for the rest of
your life not just the business you're
in no 100 I'm thinking about leaving I
have a new show if it goes it'll be in
La
um I bought a house in the desert which
I understand isn't leaving California
but
um so I plan on spending a lot more time
out there
um but right you got you got to go in
the cave and start writing yeah but I've
looked in Florida I've looked in
Nashville and I I've thought about it
which is said because La has been a
really great place an Entourage you know
part of Entourage was a love letter to
LA and how much I love that place and
how I dreamed you know my parents didn't
let me go to UCLA because they they said
you'll never come home and so I dreamed
my entire life of being out in in
California in Hollywood and uh it's a
really beautiful place and you can never
ever replace that and you can never
replace the weather which you know when
I come here and I'm sweating at eight
o'clock in the morning you know I go
this is tough but welcome to Miami yeah
so but
um I'm I'm seriously thinking about
leaving I'm having a I'm having a baby
so I cannot even comprehend right now uh
you know my my fiance walking down the
street with a baby right now because it
really does not feel safe so and and you
know again you're gonna have you know
jerk-offs like even Seth Rogen oh that's
part of life in the big city you know
getting your car stolen you know what
that's fine when you have 100 million
dollars and you can just go this but you
know when you don't I just had I had a
flat tire it ruined the week of my life
I got stuck in the desert so I just
think that right now
um I'm hoping something turns it and
people start to to wake up you know
because it is the same thing I say about
Kanye it's like yeah we want to help
everybody with mental illness but we
can't allow lunatics to be running
around the streets yeah um because we
want to want to hear what their stories
are you know let me ask you
um because I'm the only one here that
hasn't spent a decade plus of their life
in La you spent how many years of your
life 24. 24. you're there for a decade
your New York La guy I'm Miami Florida
born and raised
was it a slippery slope thing or did it
fall off the cliff and Avalanche style
since covet it fell off the cliff and
you know I mean you had to think there
were going to be some repercussions from
kovid I mean because of what was
happening and you know again for the
really rich people it seemed like oh
this is a great vacation but I have so
many friends who had businesses in La
that have been destroyed and you know it
never made sense to most of us and you
want to protect everyone that you can
but you know you just go what what was
the point of that and and it is it is a
it is a it's a tough pill to swallow and
I think we're gonna feel the effects of
this for a long long time let me ask you
a follow-up question because again born
and raised Miami like Florida has
catapulted to the top of everyone's list
since covid and you know a lot of people
will put DeSantis on a pedestal for what
he's done and I know you're saying I'm
not smart enough you're a pretty [ __ ]
smart guy
at some point is it sort of the policies
the politicians they kind of got to be
responsible for this nonsense you know
what whether it's Garcetti or Newsome
obviously obviously policies have to
have an effect but there are cyclical
situations that happen in markets in the
world like I said you know I got held up
at gunpoint in New York City in front of
the Plaza Hotel in 1990 some of the most
expensive real estate on the planet
Earth and there used to be prostitutes
standing right outside the Plaza Hotel
um those were the days great times but
New York New York was a scary scary
place the 70s which I wasn't really
around for were far worse
um so and then Giuliani cleaned it up he
did he really did and Bloomberg you know
and he did but you know it's such a it's
such a slippery slip because you can't
say [ __ ] without people saying you're
trying to Target this and that I just
want to Target criminals I want to get
them off the street I want to you know I
want to help people to try to have the
best lives they can have so you like
this Caruso guy that's running I do yeah
what do you like about them I I like
that he's a businessman who's
accomplished things I'm I'm so sick of
these [ __ ] politicians who've never
done anything and then you watch them
become rich as a politician they're
supposed to make 50 000 bucks a year and
work to try to make the world better but
they're really working for themselves
that's why you know again I have a small
following on my Instagram but I get in
trouble from both sides which I guess
I'm stupid that's a good thing but the
smart thing is that you know my friend
does a podcast with with Bill Maher and
I always say I had Bill Maher's ideas
before he says him but unfortunately I
mean he does a podcast with Bill Moore
he's got a podcast Bill Mary's got a
great podcast no I've amazing yes Club
random yeah yeah my friend's a producer
of it oh gosh and came up with a woman
is there is there is there a more
necessary voice in America these days
than Bill Maher yeah Joe Rogan but he's
he's in he's up there he's in a top 10
list but and uh Doug going off from what
you said I moved from I left La you know
I'm stand up acting and doing all that
stuff so now I'm in the comedian comedy
Department mayor I think when they
started not decriminalizing but like the
shoplifting 950 or less they're
basically giving criminals the okay to
do whatever then you say [ __ ] like
defund the police which is making cops
less eager to do their job because like
you know what [ __ ] you guys if you guys
are going to have that attitude and I
was one of those moments and I've said
it before on the podcast where I was
like you know what it's time to get the
hell out of here my mom's visiting and
we stop at a at a red light there's a
full-on fight people beating the [ __ ] of
each other right and then the lights
green people are beeping for us to go
homeless guy walks right into the middle
of the street takes her like a good [ __ ]
just I'm not even I'm not a good one you
looked like he had enough fun he was and
he's like you know looking at not just
your average one I mean my mother's in
the car and like he picks it up I mean
he had the decent
it was this moment that we're Pat you
know we're talking he's like maybe you
should move here instead of doing all
this stuff there and my mom will never
forget looks at me and she goes I think
I think it's time for you
coming up on the next answer
it was like a movie scene I'm shocked
like something crazy doesn't happen but
yeah it's it's but let me ask you
another question about um like I've said
this before again not a California guy
but is there a more Hollywood fabricated
plastic tell me what I should say guy
than Gavin Newsom I mean I I just seems
so are you trying to get him in trouble
his podcast could get canceled tomorrow
my opinion no say no Adam you're wrong
the good thing is like I said I'm
unemployed and uncancelable but I do
have personal uh friends who who have
connections to Gavin there's some so I'd
rather not speak about you know they are
all frauds okay period end of story I
mean Joe Biden Donald Trump these people
are full of [ __ ] they lie about their
backgrounds they lie about what they're
gonna do you and you know I it's just
it's that's why my frustration level is
on such a place because you really like
I did grow up and thinking people want
to be the president because they wanted
to make the place better but it's a
hundred million dollar job if you get
that job you know so why wouldn't you
want to be AOC who you know is was a
waitress and now she wants to write
books and she wants to do this and
that's why you know I like I got in
trouble because everyone thought I was
this left-wing language when Cuomo sold
that book long before his sexual
harassment thing I'm like how is this
even legal that you can be a sitting
[ __ ] governor and you write books for
five million dollars like how is this
possible that we allow this and then
again I don't want to go left or right
but like Pelosi with these trades like
how is this possibly legal that they can
let these these congressmen do insider
trading when they know what's going to
happen before it happens so yeah you
know you know what's the what's the
crazy thing is
uh uh we were talking to
uh Kanye said when I talked to Tupac
Tupac told me first go get your money
and then wreak havoc or whatever some
line like that that he talked about
Tupac told him this 20 some years ago 30
years ago in 1996 it's whatever the
timeline is Right years ago and
sometimes when you don't have a few
money you have to walk on eggshells
especially in your world yeah when you
don't have it yet uh and and you know
when you do you feel Freer you can say
whatever you want to say and I fully
understand that business model and but
sometimes people in your world are held
hostage yeah uh because of that and you
have to be part of the team because God
forbid you don't support it's going to
hurt your business and uh you want to
thinks I'm most excited about Hollywood
what's happened the last I don't know 10
years is that the netflixes of the world
have come out the Hulu's of the world
these Otts are coming out where you no
longer need a Weinstein to you know do
something with them because he's got all
this power you no longer have to go
through a gift and you don't no longer
have to go through yeah all of these
guys that at one point oh my gosh God
forbid I better please don't say this I
won't say it again I'm so sorry man now
you know I'm you do this I'm not going
to give you this movie it's like oh my
God I'm never going to get a part again
and all of my career is over with the
best part artists those guys are gone
and today they're not gone but those
guys are not as powerful as they were
before and today a Money Party here's 20
million bucks let's go make a bunch of
[ __ ] and we're gonna put it on our Ott
yeah and this is what we're gonna do the
freedom of these Otts coming out now how
has that shifted your mindset within
your industry what we're really going to
see because I I just went out and
financed my own show you know and you
still need you still have those
Gatekeepers because you still need the
distribution if you want to go big I
think where the world will be in three
years you know like comedians I don't
know if you guys ever had what Andrew
Schultz or Dave Schultz I don't know you
know he released his own album Taylor
Swift goes and makes you know goes and
makes I know she's got 400 million
people following her but she goes and
makes her album in her own home she
doesn't need anybody so we did that with
a with a pilot
um so now we'll see what happens we just
finished it now we gotta shop it around
if we somehow can't get distribution
from one of the main major platforms and
we will figure out a way that we will
release it ourselves so
um so that was really exciting to me
because the process that I did this
pilot in you know where Entourage took
you know when when I talk about how Ari
sold that in the room I was paid fifty
thousand dollars to write a script that
took two years and torture and almost
almost to the point where if you really
wanted to like break it down it was far
less than minimum wage
in L.A and over two years over two years
25 Grand bucks an hour yeah three bucks
and honestly I call I I actually said at
one point I said to my age can you call
them up and say like if they want me to
keep going like give me a little show me
the money yeah I think I think there was
like 2 500 bucks a game so so there is
there's such a feast or famine world out
there where and then you get going and
all of a sudden you get paid and then
everybody goes oh you're part of the
elites now you're part of this but I sat
there for two years busted my ass wrote
400 drafts of this script with everybody
think if people think people are
sensitive now every word was scrutinized
every [ __ ] vowel but now I did this
pilot now and we'll see what happens and
again it's not some wildly uh
politically incorrect thing and I don't
think Bill Maher is either I think it is
a very uh just like Entourage was it is
a very clear look at culture and society
as it is right now I've got Charlie
Sheen in it speaking of really this is a
real I don't want to say it I want to
see if you're comfortable saying oh yeah
yeah Charlie Sheen Martin Sheen Connolly
Dylan you know Breezy from All American
kamiko Glenn from uh from uh what are
you guys looking for what are you guys
looking for for the whole thing like in
terms of money yeah well I mean to be
honest with you I just want to make sure
we're at the right place where we can
get eyeballs on it I feel the same way
as I did about Entourage just let me get
the audience out there and then there's
so many things that I can do and this
but so we did a pilot I feel great about
it I've started writing the rest of the
season and now we'll figure it out
there the pilots out there it's not out
there anywhere but you know we've got we
got we got actually Richard whites who's
currently the Aria Manuel of of William
Morris uh representing it and we'll see
what happens fantastic what's the latest
with Charlie Sheen these days Charlie
Sheen is and I mean this sincerely so
when people talk about Second Chances
and when people talk about the drug
addicts this guy is one of the best
people I've ever worked with one of the
best people I've ever known I'll say it
to his face I don't know what he's like
if you give him a line of blow and I
hope I never find out but he is
amazing and his father I've spent a lot
of time with him too great family and
great people and you know it does speak
to that fact that you know people can
slip up and they can come back and they
can redeem themselves and he he's a
really great guy and a obviously a great
town so Doug is it is it hard pitching
uh a show to like networks and people
when they when they when and I respect
what you're saying when they see or they
hear like oh Charlie Sheen's gonna be in
it does it make them more reluctant to
be like oh [ __ ] well we want to pick it
up but who knows what he's going to be
doing in like the next two or three
years he might relapse you know what I
obviously you know I don't know what
they're saying when they see them and
we're just starting to shop it yeah but
you know that's what the show is about
Charlie Sheen is playing himself oh he's
playing you know and an ultra realistic
version of himself it's not you know
trying to make one of these cartoony you
know versions Charlie Sheen and HIV
positive Charlie Sheen who's putting it
off straight up oh yeah that is all on
the line then there's nothing like
there's no punches being pulled in this
thing at all so how's his health his
health seems great he's he's HIV
positive the medications are great the
medication for HIV are is amazing yeah
he's he's doing is working okay for you
I'm in great shape
he's doing great so that's great great
to hear by the way when you think about
him and his Pops I mean some of the best
movies man you think about it I got I
gotta show I got to show you this
because the scene with him I mean I mean
first of all the second episode two
which I already wrote which Martin told
me he read it and he cried because this
was actually so realistic to his life
but the but the the scene in the show
with them like you know and whatever
maybe Martin will forget he said he goes
I think this is better than horrible our
Wall Street Scenes wow and uh and I
think it is it's absolutely riveting and
real and I think any father-son will
relate to this and um you know and
Emilio Estevez is also their brother's
son half what what is that yeah yeah
full-on brother I believe he's his
full-on brother I mean yeah Mark didn't
want to go with the sheen last name just
said I want to be an estivist you know
what Martin Martin regrets changing his
name they're actually I mean they
they're Spanish descent I mean her last
name is actually Estevez Martin Sheen is
Ramon Estevez yeah I don't I'm I may be
pronouncing around Estevez
thank you and
um and Charlie is Carlos yeah Carlos
Estevez wow I do want to make one thing
clear to everybody that's watching I do
not have HIV because it's important for
you to say Adam was a very very good
acting in it but saying it's working out
okay thank you
you know the business model would what's
your what's your uh if a person wanted
to get into that space a a person that
wanted to get in the new SP in that
space they have distribution they have
eyeballs they know how to get a lot of
eyeballs but they're not they've never
been in Hollywood they've never made
movies but they got plenty of money
money's not the issue what would you say
would be the first two three four five
moves to get into the Hollywood space
well I think you know my partner on this
show who who put up the money for it uh
Ted foxman you know he wanted to get
into Hollywood he sold this business for
a lot of money and it's all they want to
do he loves movies and he loves film
fortunately we were friends and and
hopefully it all works out for him he
feels great about the process so far but
I think the most important thing is to
find someone you know that you believe
in you know that you like what they do
that you like their talents I think you
know with all of the guys with with
money that are coming out I think you
know that's what you do you go find a
great writer you go find a great actor
that you love step number one a writer
or is it a uh actor is there like a step
to go through it or not I think if you
have your money I mean obviously if you
can get a real star that that always
helps but I think me as a writer I think
the most important things about any TV
show or movies are the beginning and
it's the concept and it's the script I
always believe that but obviously if you
can get a major star that's going to
make it a lot easier to sell it and get
people to watch it you know so get a
writer first then after you get the
writer try to get a good star is that
kind of how yeah yeah I mean that's what
we did with this with this you know and
uh I I started talking about it on the
podcast I said you know what I'm just
like we're in the pandemic and I'm like
you know what I'm just gonna go make my
own show and that was my plan I was
gonna find what's the name of the pilot
or the show Ramble On Ramble On yeah
gotcha yeah with the sheen boys and Doug
Allen Kevin Conley oh wow yeah sick
exciting it's it's a it's a Entourage
type of a model right structure except
for today's time it's it's a half hour
um you know the interesting thing about
an Entourage when it came on and people
won't remember this now because they you
know you guys say everyone knew these
actors people really didn't some people
were like which at first insulted me
because I'm was an insecure 30 year old
and they were like is this like an
unscripted documentary thing I'm like
what I'm like do you know how many hours
I spend with every comma and every word
no these are actors this is fake so some
people have never seen Adrian were like
this is this is real he's really Vinnie
Chase yeah they really did think that
this one is these guys are the real deal
like Kevin Connolly is Kevin Conley who
quit acting and started a podcast
company in his swimming in all of the
Troubles of a startup business
especially when you've never done it and
you're now 40 years old so uh it is all
Ultra real and I think it's the next
level that people that people really
want and you see all the crappy versions
of it where they make these things that
that kind of look at this is gonna be a
very realistic grounded look at both
Hollywood and celebrity culture in
2022-23 but it's also about the world
right now Second Chances Redemption
second acts which you know you guys will
find I don't know what you're in your
30s now but like thank you yeah you get
to your you get to your 40s and 50s and
you know like like you I don't even know
when you started this but you go all
right I made money I had a lot of
success in this but what the [ __ ] is
next what do I do with the rest of my
life and how do I really find a real
purpose and the movie Sideways which I
don't know if you guys are familiar with
it but that was a big inspiration for me
one of my favorite movies yeah yeah Wine
Country Giamatti and uh that went viral
I mean I was like everybody was talking
about it for it one
Church definitely won an Oscar I'm sure
Alexander Payne was nominated but he may
have won but you know it's it's a movie
that that really speaks to people you
know he was a struggling writer trying
to figure out his life and the other one
was a struggling actor and you know that
that could sound like just a boring
thing but it really spoke to everybody
and what people go through no matter
what your level of success or failure is
you know so just to be clear everyone is
playing themselves
wow yes it's great I mean listen Charlie
and and you know
Charlie being who he is the commuting
into writer being who he is this is like
whoever's invested into this they you
couldn't position yourself better
whoever that person is they came and
worked with you guys which is obviously
we're very excited by I mean obviously I
had the advantage of our model like for
this pilot you know I got all my
Entourage crew these are all Emmy
nominated you know cinematographers and
the whole cast and crew they all worked
for far less than if we were doing it
for somebody else so so but anyway we'll
show
I love it I love it I I wish you guys
nothing but the best I could say uh it's
a very exciting if if it's anything like
Entourage and it's for today's times I
can't wait to see it myself but you know
going back to uh going back to Hollywood
you know I like to talk about who's the
greatest you know basketball player of
all time makes for great debates right
who's the greatest baseball player of
all time it's Willie Mays it's Babe Ruth
decision
actors today okay if you were to put the
top five today that are acting today
active wow who would you say oh God
you're getting me right off the top I
gotta do it I mean it's it's a Leo I
mean they use at the top yeah Christian
Bale
um Jennifer Lawrence I know I'm gonna
like leave out and like all of a sudden
I'm doing something wrong or but you
know um there's so many great talented
actors don't be diplomatically I'm
trying to come up so Leo so we got Leo
we got the bail freaking Bale is a beast
exactly it's something else I mean
Daniel Day Lewis is really good I swear
to God I was just about decided to start
interviewing of him where he's just
talking about my left foot it was like
an old just him Gary Oldman I mean I put
Gary Oldman he's freaking insane
I think he's the own he's his own yeah
Lewis is on another level they're like
he only does act like me I don't think
he has a life outside of acting
obviously he was he was retiring to be
like a shoe cobbler I'm not interested I
have no idea but I mean I remember when
I saw Lincoln which you know you just
sit and you go well how do you come up
with like a voice for Lincoln and he he
was more Lincoln than the [ __ ] penny
you were just like this guy
I mean it's it's amazing to watch but
there's there's a bunch of guys and um
who who that who make love is uh God
what Jesse Jesse uh uh Clemens is that
his name I love this guy he was on
Breaking Bad but I think he's a future
Oscar winner
um he's incredible
um
Phil Hoffman was one of my best I mean
he passed away but what a Capote I I saw
the like a round table with him and the
writers and how he got the voice and it
was I mean yeah God Rest the soul this
kid is unreal he's ridiculous yeah what
do you think about what do you think
about uh uh Shia LaBeouf what do you
think about his style of acting I mean I
think it's great yeah you know um I
don't I don't know um mentally how he is
yeah dude apparently he found God and
like he's I saw that Catholic yeah the
movie he did he was that podcast he did
with uh John Bernthal which is and I'm a
fan of both by the way yeah he's sick
I'm a fan of both of those guys but shy
what an interesting guy you know very
talented very talented like I said
Transformers wasn't Transformers when he
no longer was in it and I love Mark
Wahlberg but it's a different story when
it's him and the the girl every time I
forget her name Megan Fox
first one second one you were in it once
shy wasn't in it was it was different to
me obviously I love Mark I've never seen
a frame of a Transformers movie that
once I swear to God not one second of it
not the first or the second one I didn't
even know there was a second one
oh man just not just watch the first one
it's not my thing yeah he's he he's he's
just a very talented guy when Shia maybe
it was a kid actor thing but a lot of
what he talks about is like Hollywood
just chews you up and spits you out and
you know he sounds like an 80 year old
like yeah Haggard lady like you don't
know what it's like in Hollywood and
they've they use you and abuse you like
what is that I mean by the way that
happens it didn't happen to him he did
it to himself I could have run away with
it and had you know I mean I don't think
Mark looks at Hollywood as a place that
has chewed him up and spit them out and
that's why Kanye you're like what are
you talking about business people who
would kill to be in 1 50th of your
position you know so but it is it is
it's a tough town There's no question
about it and I've watched it I've been
out there what the day I graduated
college I went there in 1990 and I've
I've seen a lot of people come and go is
it tough because it's competitive
there's egos there's money it's just
trying to change I mean like you know
again I don't I I don't look for
anybody's empathy or pity I don't give a
flag [ __ ] but if you watch like where
Entourage suddenly went from like this
critically acclaimed popular thing to
all of a sudden [ __ ] all of a sudden it
was like every day let's re-examine
Entourage and all of its problematic
themes and yet you know and that
whether anyone it has real world effects
so the town starts hearing it and the
[ __ ] clowns and in Hollywood starts
to go well we can't we can't do that we
can't get involved with that thing we
want to go with that thing literally
they do that yeah now if you're if you
just had something if the Entourage
movie would have made a billion dollars
then I would have been able to do
whatever I want but it didn't so but it
really came out if you look at the
Entourage movie which honestly it is we
that movie tested so high that that the
president of Warner Brothers like sent
me the tracking numbers and said you
know frame this because you'll never see
it again and start writing Entourage too
and I said I will not write one syllable
until I see this movie open and the
weird thing is is you could watch the
movie and and like I know the fake
people will go oh it sucked it's exactly
what season one was which people say was
their favorite and I made strong but
when you read the reviews on it it was
all about misogyny yeah and how these
guys are this and that and the the
whether the world had changed certainly
the critics had changed you know and you
saw a world that honestly none of us saw
coming because that was probably
probably came out two years before the
metoo movement but it was it was brewing
and you know that that's fine so you
know I always say about you know you
either adapt or you die and you know
people talk about cancer culture like
it's this new thing you know Andrew Dice
Clay is a close friend of mine he was
canceled in 1990. Lenny Bruce was
canceled in the 70s so this is not new
stuff
um and the difference now is as you say
with Joe Rogan it's really hard to
really cancel somebody now is it easy
for a director who gets into trouble to
go get 50 million dollars from a studio
to make a movie no but there are other
ways like I'm doing now with the with
this new show and Joe does with a
podcast like he's not canceled even if
Spotify didn't want him on their
networks he he put it out himself and
he'd still have the same how much you
trust Rotten Tomatoes
well I think Rotten Tomatoes is just
like a a survey of of all the reviewers
right I mean so I don't know I don't I
don't really I don't really look at it
but I don't I don't know why you do you
think they're 25 up to something or uh
listen here's my model would Rotten
Tomatoes if
you go to Rotten Tomatoes pick a movie
okay just go to you know you're going to
Dave Chappelle go to Rotten Tomatoes oh
that I see what you're doing go for it
go to Rotten Tomatoes
so if you go here uh to zoom in okay so
check this out whatever the Tomato model
says I don't trust yeah the audience
score I trust so this is Dave Chappelle
special got some 99
yeah what that is like a survey of real
critics exactly so how much credibility
does that have in your space well it has
zero in my brain space but unfortunately
or not you know look at the end of the
day it's a money making business so you
can like Dave Chappelle has no problems
with that 35 because it's not going to
affect them because the audience loves
it
um click on some of the reviews let's I
mean this is three years ago edgy but
empty the the the 35 we know the world
loved it 99 I don't know if I've seen a
99 so these are like allegedly real
critics yeah exactly they'll go up a
little bit so we can read this she's a
top credit okay Chappelle is fascinating
sophisticated and wasn't her great the
colors on there I can't kid behind there
what was it there are moments in this
special that I can't get behind can get
but there were others I'm shocked that
Netflix gave the go ahead okay cool this
guy's from uh pool whatever that's just
stupid because Netflix Netflix doesn't
give the go ahead they they let Dave
Chappelle go and he did what he did and
they put it on and you can judge it
however you want so watch Eddie Murphy
Delirious from oh my God which I you
know I'll get canceled because I I
memorized every single line of this yeah
you and me both I mean you know that it
was a different time now maybe obviously
you don't want to abuse any of the
people that he may have been making fun
of which again I called comedy though
it's called comedy make people laugh
like you know I went to I went to the
American Film Institute which was uh is
considered like you know one of the best
film schools in the country and the
first film I did what they do with you
is they um it's crazy they you show your
film and to the whole crowd of students
and everybody which is probably like two
or three hundred people then you have to
go sit on stage and you can't say a word
while they critique you oh God so I put
my first film on which I had David
Schwimmer pre-friendsen I think and a
couple other people and uh everybody
laughed their asses off and I was like
the only comedy guy there everybody
lasted left their asses off then I get
up on stage and people go funny funny
funny funny funny which it wasn't meant
to be much more than that and then the
the professor he starts going wow
and then they all started attacking me
like one after the other how useless
this was how pointless this was how how
it didn't change the world it didn't
affect anybody blah blah blah so then
and this at the time
the school for the second year only like
12 out of the 30 directors would get
into this program I mean like Darren
Aronofsky didn't get into the second
year last program okay I was the only
one who did not apply but I made a film
that made fun of the school I had the
the teacher of the school was like you
know like you know I don't want to go to
the Jewish thing but he was like a Nazi
commander and like whatever and when
when I put my film up that everybody
laughed at and he turned on me all the
all the students turned into sheep and
they chased me out like Frankenstein out
of the school he did not show up at the
screening of the school the only time
the entire year and I had students there
who are friends of mine who actually
people who worked on ramble on that
didn't want to work on that project
because they were scared they'd get
canceled at the school at AFI in 1991
and I think that's part of the whole
thing you you of course you have a fear
and that's why I say while while I
wanted Adidas to throw Kanye out I get
the conversations we're not [ __ ] easy
and I and I would love to say that I
would just walk away from a hundred
million dollars right now not to work
with somebody who who had not opinions
again that's the thing that people say
by the way he's entitled to his opinion
no if you think all Jews suck you're not
entitled to that [ __ ] opinion okay I
don't know what else to say it's stupid
you're ignorant and it makes no sense to
anyone who has a brain but
I understand there are a lot of things
at play when you get into these
situations and when you're talking about
Chappelle who is clearly the greatest
living comedian right now he may say
something that offends you he may say
something that offends me I'm sure he
has but if it's funny it's funny like
Ricky Gervais show did you watch that
one I mean I mean she's on a whole
different level you know and I'm talking
afterlife did you watch after no I
haven't seen after a lot I mean anything
I watch with him I'm Blown Away you talk
about
anti-pc stuff that he says and gets away
with because I think like Larry David
these are just and it's why I say and
and I'm not even putting myself anywhere
near those leagues but but I believe I
know how to walk those lines and I walk
them in 2003 nobody was ever coming
after us for Entourage in 2003 I believe
the same thing with the new show but
afterlife Ricky Gervais show
he's such a [ __ ] genius and Rotten
Tomatoes let's see how good after life
is have you guys of course Comedians in
Cars Getting Coffee with uh yeah yeah
trust me watch the episode of Ricky
Gervais he says you know what I will I
will I'm telling right now he's still
the stand-up comedy joke to Jerry
Seinfeld and Jerry almost falls on the
floor it's one of the funniest oh I know
it's the uh
how brilliant is that joke all right so
71 now again you know the show the
show's
depressing at the same time it's about
like him losing his wife but there's
things he does in that show that you go
okay I can't believe anyone but nobody's
telling Ricky Gervais like don't do this
you know and and by the way even on
Entourage and HBO like Carolyn Strauss
who was you know the the head at the
time there were some things that I wrote
and she's like I like I don't like this
but I'm not telling you what to do it's
your thing go go do it and I think
that's that's how it should be and again
that's why let Kanye he he should be on
Twitter spewing his garbage it's sad and
people should tell him why it is but
99 to 37 with Kanye when it comes down
to his special he did just tell him you
know Chappelle yeah it's just tell you
it tells you Tanya has a comedy special
coming out now everyone yeah no no it's
just I brought up Rotten Tomatoes I
wonder like in your world does anybody
give a [ __ ] does it do people call you
and tell you well your score sucks I'm
not going to give you another you know
we're not going to invest into the next
project but apparently you don't really
care much about it well I mean if I had
a movie coming out I certainly would
want the critics to like it you know
because it let's get hurt let's test
somebody make money than the critics
give a movie you like give a movie you
like name a movie you like I don't know
pick a movie that's new okay go to top
gun I mean everybody like Top Gun go to
Maverick Top Gun will be should be good
on both sides that is pretty you know I
don't think they offended anybody with
that okay good that was actually by the
way they literally didn't even say who
the enemy was on top yeah which is like
who they attacked they didn't you don't
even know who they attacked yeah it was
in the desert but you don't know which
desert it was in give me another one
give me another one that maybe is a
little old school okay good to Old
School
old school today oh you know what Tropic
Thunder would be a good one oh that'd be
great 60 exactly that's offensive go to
Tropic Thunder go to Tropic Thunder 16
versus 86.
Tropic Thunder let's see if it's still
oh okay cool oh wow which is crazy 71
but that that's flipped that's reversed
yeah well that was a long time ago you
know you also don't know who's coming
out I mean you ever read uh you ever
read your podcast reviews I mean I get
Podcast reviews like [ __ ] you out
there's too much advertising one star
you know like you don't know what
people's agenda is or what their their
thing is but
I don't want to say I don't care but I
would prefer that the audience is like
me than the critics I think that's a
perfect timing today's sponsors Rotten
Tomatoes
thank them for the reviews they give us
speaking of Chappelle I mean talk about
meteoric I mean he he was doing his
thing in movies and all that yeah but
when Chappelle Show came out I want to
say that was that 0.405 is that what it
was three or four yeah it's right around
04 for sure yeah
yeah there's no chance that people can
do what he was doing he was doing
Whiteface yeah yeah like he flipped it
on people you can do white face though I
think yeah okay well that's a whole
other question Eddie Murphy if you can't
do blackface you can do white women
never see Eddie Murphy I mean yeah yeah
you know I mean did you build the black
white supremacist the blind guy by the
way I don't want to get into this
because it's only trouble but Billy
Crystal played Sammy Davis yeah I think
he won Emmys and I have no idea whether
African-Americans were offended at the
time and and if they were of course you
feel bad about it but I just wish I
don't know I just wish comedy was comedy
and you know what like I don't know even
Sarah Silverman said Jews should play
Jews I mean Jim Sheridan you were
talking about Daniel Day-Lewis I think
Jim Sheridan the director of my left
foot apologized for not I think I don't
wanna I hope I'm not making that up for
not casting an actual paraplegic now
there's not a [ __ ] able-bodied being
on the world that could play that part
but you know we're getting into this
place where you know now uh Darren
aronowsky's actually got a new movie out
and I read critics going why wouldn't
they cast a real 400 pound man why would
they put him in a bodysuit and you go
this is a [ __ ] movie It's supposed to
be people acting like different human
beings that's the point and and it's art
is supposed to hopefully hopefully that
movie helps people empathize with with I
don't even know if I'm allowed to say
fat I don't know yeah don't you ever
yeah by the way I'm a little fat I'm
skinny what about Eddie Murphy playing a
bunch of different fat characters
Professor which by the way that was the
first time I really got aware of
Chappelle and The Nutty Professor that's
where you played the Show Box guy yeah
he was the comedian yes I mean it's it's
still that you love the funniest scene
you know what I watched a lot like um
Don Rickles who was one of my favorites
I watch all those Dean Martin all those
roasts and you want to talk about comedy
there was black there was Latino and
everybody's [ __ ] on everybody and
everybody went home and they were okay
listen all those great legendary Mel
Brooks and Carl Reiner these guys are
liberals and if you watch Blazing
Saddles which now
there'll be warnings or the jerk which I
always thought you know now I'm it makes
me uncomfortable to watch it but Steve
Martin says I don't know if you remember
the line but I remember the whole movie
these guys say to him now that he's
successful he has to be careful about
the n-words and Steve Martin who was
raised by an African yeah American
Family proudly stands up and says
I am
the n-word you know and I'm sure now I
don't know they probably edit it out but
I Know Carl Reiner was a uh and I don't
want to say the word liberal because now
the word liberal is [ __ ] horrible but
he was a person who believed in equality
for everybody and he was trying to move
the needle forward as Norman Lear was
and and Mel Brooks so it's just it's
very upsetting to see all that did you
see you said the fat can you say it or
not did you see the Taylor Swift fat
thing that she had to remove the clip
out of her new um did you see that or no
so they're she's standing on the skin
there's a she's standing on a scale in
the music video and here let me send you
this it's a the best one is Buzzfeed
because BuzzFeed definitely is a uh Buzz
Kill but let me just send this one to
you
um show this one here yeah it's from
BuzzFeed that's the one zoom in a little
bit so we can see it yeah so there's
remove the fat scale from her anti-hero
music video on Apple music
and keep going up keep going up to see
the picture read the warning though
where's the warning
disorders
keep going up warning keep going up
Taylor Tyler keep going okay however a
scene where Taylor stands shamefully on
a scale that reads man are you fat has
received some backlogs what is going my
concern is more her small little pinky
toe than it is the fat concept I mean
it's truly it's truly scary what's going
on and and you know everybody should
embrace who they are and everybody's got
their limitations but also everybody
should try to be as healthy as possible
I mean it's just that simple and
here's here's what's been proven okay uh
uh uh being skinny is not healthy okay
we know that like the being scary
anorexic of course but for sure being
overweight and fat has no at all zero
benefits to anybody yeah uh and and for
for people to not be able to talk logic
and just openly talk about that that's
very very problematic when you can't
talk about that so they forced her to
remove this just so you know from the
music video I think it's funny yeah but
you can't you can't doesn't hurt
anybody's feelings this is not a Babylon
B article by the way this is this is a
uh this is a true it's not satire it's
actually what happened by the way you
see what it says though has some
backlash and that's the problem like who
is this backlash from and and where are
the other people on the other side to go
you know what I want to see what Taylor
Swift thinks is funny I want to actually
like get inside of the knowledge of
these artists and what they really think
instead of being you know pasteurized
through everything so I'm just wondering
if if we're raising just a generation of
freaking wussies where just words hurt
them if you're not getting your pronoun
the way you want it you're offended like
right now we've got bigger concerns like
China's coming for us from a global
macro perspective like you think China
is don't be don't be anti-asian don't
don't do that I'm sorry I'm not don't do
that I'm not don't because you just hey
hey Adam oh did I just uh but what he
didn't do and again I'm not I'm not on
either side I don't know who I'm gonna
vote for in anything right now but he
didn't go with China yeah China that's
his accent though no that was him going
[ __ ] you I'll say whatever the [ __ ] I
want and I don't care what ramifications
it has but the reality was it is what
they did it is what you could also say
this this disease came from China but he
also could have said listen I need
everybody to remember what this country
did during World War II yeah and turning
Japanese people we don't turn on people
because of what they are or what the
government by the way you think the
[ __ ] Chinese people are enjoying
their government you think they like
being on 24-hour lockdowns with
helicopters going around or they're
[ __ ] dogs getting beaten with sticks
in the street yeah so I just think you
can say if you're the Goddamn president
and by the way Biden sucks also with his
you know turning everyone against each
other when he was supposed to be the
unifier but you can get on and go look
we believe this virus came from China
but do not a do not blame Chinese people
certainly don't blame people in America
who are trying to live their lives and
and if he said that I believe it would
have an effect whether it's stopped one
person from getting attacked you you
live in Utopia that's what you you live
in a uh you're writing a little too much
and you're living in a imaginary world
that's not real so tell me how what pre
president before him stop it stop it so
you you want you want to go up against a
country that says they want to take over
the world by 2025 made in China you want
a soft guy going up against them with
the current way we're handling China I
don't know you you're gonna need a guy
that's got the brass balls to face those
guys quite frankly I don't care if it's
him I don't care if it's Clinton I don't
care if it was a JFK a liberal a
republican someone that's got brass to
face a country like that I'm
I think you're just offended that he the
way he says China sounds like a vagina
but that's how he talks by the way um
it's not even that China I can China
offended I just know that that's the
type of stuff that causes a bunch of
[ __ ] animosity in this country with
people oh my gosh you know then that
just you've been in L.A too much and
you've softened up a little I'm not soft
at all you're from New York to go back
to the New York days New York people are
jobs from New York three of you guys
here I'm a guy that lived in L.A 20 some
years too too sensitive on stuff to say
when you don't it's again it's not about
my sensitivity yeah it's about how it
look at the [ __ ] country we're almost
at a Civil War who though who caused
that it doesn't matter who caused it
it's you need someone to come out and
speak them yeah I don't disagree with
that no [ __ ] other purpose in life
than to try to keep dude can you imagine
if for three and a half years people
said Doug Ellen's financed through
freaking North Korea yeah and everyone
in Hollywood starts believing it and no
one wants to do business with you how
would you like that so let's just say if
they said it's coming I just want them
how is it where's that coming from for
for three and a half years they said
this guy was tied to China
so is that okay for them to do every
politician has gone through [ __ ] I mean
again now maybe Clinton deserved it with
with the Monaco
but again none of my business I don't
care between him and his wife the
president of the United States that's
just so unclear so everyone doesn't
attack me as a [ __ ] libtard I lost
one of my oldest friends because he's a
[ __ ] cult-living Trump lunatic it's
not us I don't I am not a liberal at all
but the president of the United States
which again Biden did the same [ __ ] oh
the maggots are killing us the president
of the United States should say every
[ __ ] day we need to all come together
that's his only purpose he's a [ __ ]
idiot anyway both of them are by the way
they are these are not like the great
intelligence I know he wants to show us
you know that's a safe cop out and and
let me challenge you that's my opinion
it's a safe cop-out and and the reason
why I say it's a safe compound it's
because it's it's when you know you know
if you were to measure policy to policy
which is what matters that's what we
should be talking about we don't but you
weren't worried about that from 16 to
2020. you were not you weren't worried
about policies you weren't worried about
Ukraine you weren't worried about time
you weren't worried about Iran you
weren't worried about Afghanistan you
weren't worried about that stuff you
weren't worried about the economy you
weren't worried about unemployment you
weren't worried about any of that stuff
the only thing you were worried about is
this guy cannot stop talking [ __ ] and 90
of the stuff that he says on Twitter
should be that's what everybody was
pissed off about fine credibility is
true you're right he did too much of
that but today policies tell me what
policies has made America better the
last two and a half years again like I
said yes I'm not talking yeah policy at
all but you said policy is what matters
the most that's what we should be
talking about that's what we should be
talking about and that's and that's why
you see though you know
you like these policies and you're going
to get them back and that's what
elections are for and that's what it's
all about but I just believe the
President should do his best to keep
people calm that's what I believe uh 100
we're on the same page with that I I I
think uh uh using too much of emotions
to pin people against each other again
it's a very effective marketing method
that both sides use but unfortunately
sometimes it divides but I guess that's
what I'm saying the biggest thing about
the president they shouldn't be so
[ __ ] thin-skinned I'm not saying I'm
not right by the way you're saying what
would I do first of all I would never
want to be president that's first of all
second of all like we talked about this
on the podcast if like Connolly and I
Kevin Conley if we were King I'd be a
very violent King but I'm not I was not
voted in and I did not you know say
which Trump did by the way just like
Biden right before he became president
he said I'm gonna bring everyone
together and I said right right before
he started I go you know what he he won
the election how he had to they always
get nasty and you know what he's gonna
get I don't mean nice you don't have to
be nice but you have to [ __ ] bring
people together because right now to me
the country it was bad even in 2016 when
you weren't worrying about economics you
were worried that your best friend
wanted to punch you in the face because
you thought you liked this one or that
so I I just think it's a it's a sad time
it really is and um and I think that the
fact that we could turn you say and why
I say I am not on any side there is no
turning on Cops on January 6th just like
there's no turning on Cops at a mall in
[ __ ] Minneapolis it's the same [ __ ]
you cannot hit a cop and what I believe
police reform
now we need to the existing laws need to
be you know used like cops cannot be
violent but not all cops are violent and
we need cops desperately it's just like
oh we're learning that it's so stupid
that it's it's it's mind-boggling yeah
by the way we had the mayor of Westwood
oh and and the mayor Westwood was uh
talking about getting rid of cops and
well what they're going to replace it
with is it was a yellow jacket
psychologists yeah by the way I've been
I've been in therapy for 20 years never
done a [ __ ] thing of good for me I
want to go up to a guy with a machine
gun and go I'd really like to talk to
you let me see what's troubling you
today yeah lay down on the sidewalk yeah
you know I got in trouble for that when
Biden said the cop should shoot people
like in in the [ __ ] calves yeah and
and the truth is is if anyone's ever
worked with a gun and my son is
volunteered my son played Ari's son on
the show has volunteered with police for
since he was literally 10 years old oh
wow and and to think that you would say
something so stupid if someone like let
me aim for his [ __ ] femur while he's
trying to kill me you know with whatever
but sucks like you got to stop right now
I'm sorry hang tight for a second yeah
yeah okay go ahead stop do what you're
doing yeah you're out in the military
yeah aim for Center Mass the whole time
it's just oh wow
I was doing something no no no I'm
role-playing you talking to you guys you
have to stop the threat exactly and I'm
not interested in in unfortunately
discussing what the problem is I would
rather figure it out after I'm alive and
I can still provide for my children but
I think it's it's a really sad thing my
question though is
did they ever believe this or was this a
thing that they thought could get them
some attention get them into power I
don't know I think you're right I think
that's what they did it's just what
everybody says during a certain time
they support it and then when it doesn't
work they said we never agreed to that
that was the other guy's idea not all
right I was telling my son that during
the whole election I'm like like most of
these people don't believe this for one
second you know but
Doug what do you think about Elon Musk
buying a Twitter and firing everybody so
it fired 75 you heard about it he fired
a CEO he fired a CFO he fired a bunch of
City Suites he came to put up the
picture of him going to work day one
with a kitchen sink did you see that
yeah you walked up to the headquarters
what do you think about him buying a
Twitter I saw everybody put the I don't
know if you saw it but all over Twitter
they put you know Ari Gold from
Entourage walking in yes yes
which is probably like that's
problematic you're you're teaching
people to shoot people in the office but
I think my hope
is is really hopeful because I mean by
the way I've been suspended from
Instagram I've been I you know how many
times you have a dirty Jew and and this
and I responded and and
it's so bizarre because I watch Michael
rapaporto I think you know it's just
funny as hell he doesn't seem to get
suspended he's much more aggressive than
I am but I I got suspended for three
months I couldn't get in touch with
anybody
um and it was just for responding to
people who were saying [ __ ] to me so I
hope you know again threats violent
threats
um should not be on Twitter I'm gonna
kill you or let's go blow up a building
but you should be able to speak freely I
believe that 100 you know what what so
what's the kitchen sink reference here
with Elon Musk like meaning he bought
the whole throwing everything out except
the kitchen sink you know that's pretty
cool that's funny he's downstairs and
then upstairs all the guys upstairs like
wait he's here with the kitchen's saying
oh we're [ __ ] we gotta get out of here
his gun was he tweeted uh let that sink
in on Twitter let that I'll tell you it
looks a lot thinner than that picture on
the yacht yeah
by the way though he got shamed and he
did something yeah by the way people
have shamed me all the time yeah you're
too fat you're too skinny you too this
you do that so I mean you try to improve
you're too funny Doug by the way I've
never said that did you did you uh
people are losing their mind did you say
did you or did you
I see what you're trying to do here he's
trying to spit it on me I got offended
by this guy calling me a Jew but uh no
people are losing their minds they're
going crazy over what's going on with
him today and what's gonna happen you
know God right now I tweeted this
morning I said a good day for free
thinkers a bad day for cancer culture
disciples because he said the bird is
freed and you should see Elon tweeted
that Elon tweeted uh the bird is freed
and I retweeted saying a good day for
free thinkers a bad day for cancel uh
culture disciples there are literally
people
who are losing their minds knowing this
guy owns Twitter or not and you know he
wants to keep himself as a CEO do you
realize when I take it private you
realize what this means this means if
he's CEO he's CEO of Tesla he's CEO of
SpaceX this guy's got three jobs as CEOs
of
multi-multi-billion dollar companies
yeah you think America's getting a lot
of sleep boring can I ask you a question
has he uh all the people that were
canceled like Trump and everybody have
they what when's their I'm pretty sure
he's going to read Trump's not going to
go back though he's not not going to go
back okay
he's not going to go back I think that
is a horrible move on Trump said how do
you not go back to Twitter he'll be back
that's awesome I don't believe that for
one second and by the way he may he may
add truth social to every single tweet
if he's smart that's what he would do
but uh he'll be back in two seconds
he'll be back
if he wants to drive value to truth he
shouldn't if he wants to drive value to
truth social he shouldn't come back to
Twitter because truth social was a spack
and a lot of people put up a lot of
money and to keep those guys loyal to
money guys yeah you kind of got to stay
on just getting on Twitter to his I
don't know how many people did he have
100 million he had a lot of people like
a lot to start telling them hey start
switching over I don't think it's oh
that part is a different story I don't
think is logging on to True social what
I don't know how you do it what's an app
what anyone who's Center or anywhere
left of center is even thinking about
truth social
I've never been on so I have no idea and
your center right yeah I've never been
on truth so that's my point but what I'm
telling you dude forget about this for a
second if you own truth social okay and
he owns a lot of it and he can make real
good money off truth social if he does
it right if you aren't true social
you don't want your tweets to be put on
Twitter you don't want your post to be
on Twitter you want it to be on Truth
social so people want to find out what
the hell you're talking about that's
free advertisement for you but he'll
he'll say I got more to say on truth
social he'll get but he can't control
himself I actually don't think that he
won't be able to stop he loves tweeting
he won't be able to no no no the guy
can't help himself and by the way every
media platform in America misses him
CNN's prophets miss him of course a lot
of people lost their jobs it's all a big
movie and we're all suckers people miss
this guy CNN 1 000 is hoping behind the
curtains that he runs and he wins
because that's the old that's that's
when they were at their Peak Russia
raised me the money guys maybe the money
yeah well what I'm saying is once he was
gone and that that whole Russia and then
he's gone and and it they just fell
apart there's nothing there's no covet
there's no nothing for them to talk
about so they better they better be
hoping that he comes back how soon after
midterms do you think he announces his
candidacy five seconds right then and
there right he's just wait until after
midnight midterm especially now that
it's looking like it's gonna be I mean
that's why I'm saying it's all a movie
like it was going to be a red wave and
then all of a sudden the abortion issue
came out and was like oh the whole world
changed and it didn't and now we're
exactly where they thought they were
going to be six months ago I think
Michael Moore thinks that it's going to
be a Blue Wave still as of like I guess
so as of one as of I don't know when was
that so
the guy who said that he thought Trump
would win in 2015. so he said recently
though yes again I I only like I
shouldn't listen to the polls because
Trump said I shouldn't and he was right
but I I don't know what happened to
Pelosi's husband blue tsunami how long
ago was that three days ago three days
ago well how what kind of what kind of
polling are you looking at when you
think there's going to be a Blue Wave
all of a sudden maybe again well maybe
people saw it you know they were
inspired I went to high school with
Michael Cohen okay really yeah and when
he said what polls what polls I think I
texted him I'm like is there something
wrong with you and there wasn't he was
he was right so Michael Cohen you went
to high school you're texting Michael
Cohen yeah Texas is there anybody that's
done a 180 more than that guy
yes there's plenty of people and uh and
and and that's why I think we're all
suckers I've always been just the same
and I'm like I look at a lot of them I
go like just just [ __ ] tell my
girlfriend all the time I should be a
sociopath I mean I could do so much
better as a [ __ ] sociopath than
trying to be like truthful and honest
but and I'm not saying Michael cohn's
Associated I like Michael and Doug asked
what happened with Nancy Pelosi's
husband did something happen with her
with her husband recently well the drunk
driving thing was months ago something
just happened with but I think you guys
were talking about him today right
breaking news
Hammer what what zoom in where'd you see
Hammer was he right there
just click on that what Paul Pelosi
husband of house Speaker Nancy Lewis
attacked with a hammer at home not by
her though
by his wife zoom in by a male assailant
what that broke again what San Francisco
what do you expect yeah it's expecting a
cement for Recovery Jesus
register statement there's no FBI
interesting yeah I guess you know what
that's my point and maybe you think I
live in Utopia but I think we're getting
into a place where we're gonna start
seeing stuff like this like and again
whoever you agree with or don't agree
with there's gonna be it's just getting
more violent that's what it feels like
to me so I would like to go to the
Utopia that you think I live in you live
in that world I think I've always been
ahead of you and I'm watching I'm
watching this drive off a [ __ ] cliff
right now that's what I see like you
know it's like the movie Never Ending
Story remember Never Ending Story yeah I
would love to live in that okay I would
love to sites but does she live in San
Francisco or is she in L.A she's got or
Sacramento she's everywhere
I mean I haven't recently and I have no
interest right now but I've been there
and it's a beautiful is it way worse
than LX I know we've been saying it's
way worse than LA from everything I hear
you it's like port Portland and San Fran
are pretty much the same people just
zombies in the streets and it's homeless
and it's crime and did you see billboard
though is interesting Bill Byrd is like
talking about the difference between
homeless people 30 years ago and now it
was really really funny because it was
like 30 years ago they were just you
know you got to watch it I don't want to
try to imitate Bill Burr but it was
really funny because 30 years ago you
did not have this fear of homeless
people they you know now you really do
and they seem so I don't know what I
don't know what changed in the in the
homeless world but it's it's not social
media I saw a homeless guy being like
hey guys follow me on my YouTube channel
you're homeless buddy what are you doing
right now you have a cell phone the
mental the mental mentally ill situation
is just getting worse by the way if a
homeless person started a YouTube
channel documenting what their lives
look like I actually think that channel
would blow up if a person from L.A no no
seriously yeah I'm actually being very
what you just did right now if a person
in La who's truly homeless documented
what's really going on of a life first
of all within six months he's not
homeless anymore
but that's I would want to see what's
going on but I again I don't I I feel
terrible for homeless people but a lot
of them do not they don't want to be
indoors they want to keep this life yeah
and also they're outdoor and you're
joking about the social media there is
some communication going on I had a guy
homeless guy uh come to my house at 2 30
in the morning and I'm way up in the
hills nobody comes there I don't get
trick-or-treaters I don't get neighbors
I don't get anything and this guy came I
have two German Shepherds I have four
legally obtained weapons yes and um in
California yeah this is about two months
ago and I have it on video too and it
was terrifying and and my girl and I was
also high as hell and
my my girlfriend you know doorbell rings
my dogs go nuts they're at the window
and you can see them and you wouldn't
want to walk into my house I don't think
unless you're crazy and I I watch them I
have it all on video him going and and
it's sad because he's muttering to
himself he'll kill the dogs whatever and
I I answered with my my highness and my
gun and I'm like hello and he asked me
for an address like asked he said is
this this address not in a Clear Tone
but he said it and I said no and he
walked away muttering about killing my
dogs something like that and then the
next day on citizens the address he
asked for there was a break and what I
think was happening because it was a
house that was for sale
they get they squat so I don't think he
I don't think he was coming to kill me
or anything like that I think he was
coming looking for an empty home so he
can squat in so that particular homeless
guy wanted to be on and I just want to
say just you know not my Utopia but I
have done the the Chrysalis uh is is a
charity that helps homeless people and I
I've done some stuff with them and there
are a ton of great people out there that
are hard on their luck that do need help
for sure but we have to do something
about the violence yeah and the dangers
every every Christmas morning at 4 a.m
We would you we would get together on my
office in Granada Hills or Northridge
and we did this for 10 years and we
would go with started with like 10 of us
ended up being with 150 of us we'd go to
uh Skid Row we'd be there by 5 30 6
o'clock Christmas morning yeah and then
we would take pillows blankets
toothpaste toothbrush would go to the
McDonald's down the street by a few
hundred you know cheeseburgers whatever
it is we take them in the morning and
we'd spend two hours with those guys and
it was a Paradigm Shift type of an
experience to be around them and talking
to them yeah hey how did you end up here
are you trying to get out what caused
you to get here what was the turning
point just conversation wise and you'd
be amazed a lot of them have different
stories and some of them chose this life
he chose this life meaning not chose it
like they want to be homeless it's
you know of course some of them was bad
decisions there was one family that was
a former accountant and he was doing
very well for himself some bad decisions
his family was there but it's a variety
of different stories but some eventually
this becomes their life this is kind of
the life it's also it's a lot here in
the military a lot of vets and who have
serious people
a lot of addicts
um you know it's it's a sad situation
but either way like I said it's
something's got to be done so that
people feel safe and and that they're
safe so so yeah go ahead George Carlin
one my favorite community of all time
said you know they were about the war
and everything but they don't there's
nothing to help homelessness there's no
war there's one you know everything but
there's never a war on homelessness
because there's no money in it for them
to help these people he goes you find a
way for these corporations to make money
homelessness is cleaned up well the the
great podcast enjoyed it Doug appreciate
you for coming no thanks for having me
can you tell the audience about your
podcast we're going to put the links
below as well so they can find you I got
a victory the podcast which uh is with
two of the guys from Entourage but we we
do all sorts of stuff there Mark Cuban's
been on and the DK medcap Julius Randle
but we talk Entourage and other stuff
and I also have a podcast Ramble On
which is uh the uh official podcast of
my unofficial show Ramble On and uh we
talk about the whole process of making a
independent pilot financing it casting
getting the whole thing so awesome let's
put that link below brother appreciate
you for coming out tell me this is our
last podcast of the week I hope I have a
podcast this afternoon
no no we finished we left here at one
o'clock last night we were at one
o'clock in the morning to when we
finished up and yesterday we did a few
of them so you got one today yes four
o'clock Natalia and I saw us cast only
here on VT okay fantastic have a great
weekend everybody one jededia's got one
at one o'clock Vinnie's got funny news I
got a new sketch that week as a vampire
a vegan vampire vegan vampire
hilarious anyways take care everybody
have a good weekend bye-bye bye-bye
thanks guys